[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, everyone.
What's up?
It's Rob Dodson.
Today on Polycasts,
I want to teach you
a very powerful pattern
for extending your element
prototypes using behaviors.
Behaviors are going to unlock
a totally new world for you.
Also, I want to make sure you
all stick around to the end
because we're giving away
swag during Q&A time.
We've got things like
hoodies, shirts, stickers,
lots of awesome stuff.
So be sure to hang out for that.
All right.
Enough yakking.
Let's dive in.
So what exactly is a behavior?
Well, in a nutshell, a behavior
is a little module of code
that you can mix in to
your element's prototype,
giving your element's prototype
additional properties,
listeners, and even methods.
Now, you may be familiar
with doing something similar
using inheritance.
But there are a few
issues with inheritance
that behaviors help solve.
For example, let's
say you have a menu
and you want it to highlight
whichever one of its children
is currently selected.
And because that's a really
useful functionality,
you may pull it out and abstract
it into a parent element.
Now you can have
multiple elements that
inherit from that parent and get
that same functionality, which
is great.
But what if you want to also
add multi select behavior
to just two of these elements?
You don't want to
duplicate the code.
So you could put that
up here in the parent.
But that means that
this element down here
is going to have to
inherit all of that code
even if it doesn't use it.
It's kind of forced to
take in all this cruft.
Another issue is
multiple inheritance.
So let's say I want to add a
cool animation ripple effect
to all of these elements.
It doesn't make sense to
put that in this parent
because this parent
has one job, which
is dealing with selection.
So I might end up building
kind of an inheritance
chain like this, which is sort
of a kludgy way of solving
that problem.
This is where behaviors
really shine because they
solve both of these issues.
A Polymer element can hold
an array of behaviors,
meaning we can mix in as much
functionality as we want.
So our menu could have
a selectable behavior
to support highlighting
in one of its children.
Then it could add in multi
select behavior if it needs it.
And finally, it could add in
that ripple animation behavior.
Because you can pick and
choose the behaviors that
get added to your
component, you have
extremely fine grained
control of the code
that goes into your element.
And that eliminates
cruft, and it also
makes your element
easier to reason about.
So now that you understand
why behaviors are important,
the next step is to learn
how to implement them
in your own components.
Let's check that out.
Behaviors exist
as global objects.
So it's important to
give them a namespace.
I'm just going to
go ahead and create
a namespace called MyBehaviors.
And the behavior I'm
actually going to implement
is called PressedBehavior.
And a behavior is
going to look just
like the prototype
for a Polymer element.
So that means it can
have a properties object.
Those properties will be mixed
into my elements properties.
So here, I'm going to
create a properties object
with a property called pressed.
It's a Boolean that
defaults to false,
and it's set to read only.
So I don't want anyone
to set this value.
I just want it to change
in response to events.
I can also add listener
objects to this element,
just like you would
with a Polymer element.
I'm going to listen for
mousedown and mouseup events.
I'm going to attach those to
these two handlers-- addPressed
and removePressed.
I'm also going to a
prefix these handlers
with a little underscore.
And that is to signify that
these are protected methods.
So they're not public.
I don't want the outside
world calling them.
Then I'm going to add
the implementation
for these methods.
So I'm just going to
add two functions here
for addPressed
and removePressed.
And they're just going
to add the pressed class
or remove it from
the class list.
I can also create
abstract methods.
So maybe I don't provide
an implementation here,
but the element that
uses this behavior
could provide its
own implementation.
So I'm going to create two
abstract methods, one called
onPressStart and one
called onPressEnd.
And I'm going to mark
these both as abstract.
So again, no codes
going in here.
But someone who uses this
behavior can implement
their own version
and these will fire
when addPress or
removePress happens.
I can even add life cycle
callbacks to this behavior.
So I can go up here and
add a created callback.
And this is going to be
executed after the elements own
life cycle methods have
had a chance to run.
So here, I'm just going
to log to the console
that an object using this
behavior is in the DOM.
Next, I'm going
to create a button
element to leverage that
behavior that I just wrote.
So I'm going to import
the behavior's definition
the same way that I would
import the definition
for another Polymer
element that it depends on.
Then, down here in
its behaviors array,
I can just drop in the name of
the behavior that I'm using.
So I'm going to use my
namespace here, MyBehaviors.
And the name of the
behavior is PressedBehavior.
And now I can add
some CSS to take
advantage of that press class.
So up here at the top, I'm
going to write a style tag.
And I'm going to use
the host selector
to target the pressed class.
And when it is present
on this button element,
I want it to run an
animation called bounce.
And the bounce animation is
just a keyframe animation
that I created right here.
So over in Chrome, I'm going
to pop open my DevTools
so you can see what's going on.
I will find the element
in the document.
So here it is.
And when I click on it, you'll
see that it's going to animate
and that class is
going to show up.
When I let go, the
class gets removed.
So I click on it, it animates.
The class shows up,
and then it disappears.
Now let's try this again
with another element.
And this time, I'm going to use
one of those abstract methods.
So it's the exact same
process as before.
I'm going to import
the behavior.
I'm going to add it to this
element's behaviors array.
And then, after
that's set up, I'm
going to write an implementation
of the onPressEnd method.
And I'm just going to have
it alert a little message
that I've come up with.
So when that is ready to go,
last thing I'm going to do
is add some styles.
So I'm going to add-- again,
the host selector here,
which is targeting
the press class.
This time, it's going to add
a box shadow to the element.
So back over in the document.
Again, pop-up on the DevTools.
You can see I've got
my input element here.
When I click on it, it's
going to get that box shadow.
The press class is added.
And when I let go, that
alert is going to fire.
Also, I can go
over to the console
and you can see that the
created life cycle callback
that I implemented in the
behavior is firing twice
because I have two elements that
are each using that behavior.
Now, this behavior that
we've been building
is a great starting point
but a little contrived
for the sake of this demo.
If you want to see some
really powerful behaviors,
go check out the
element catalog.
There, you'll find behaviors
for doing custom input field
validation as well as
behaviors for accessibility.
The iron-a11y-keys-behavior
for instance,
adds a key bindings object that
lets you map key combinations
to handlers.
It also normalizes key codes
across different platforms,
which is really useful.
Finally, you've got
the neon animation
set, which heavily
uses behaviors
to define animatable elements.
In fact, now that you
understand behaviors,
we can start talking
about the animation
elements in the next video.
So I hope you found
this enlightening.
Behaviors really
change the way you
think about adding
functionality to your elements,
and they open up a lot
of interesting avenues.
That's it for this week, folks.
Be sure to click that
little Subscribe button down
at the bottom.
If you have questions
for me, leave them
down in the comments.
I do try to read and
answer all those if I can.
As always, thank so
much for watching,
and I'll see you next time.
Hey, guys.
What's up?
It's Rob.
Q&A time.
Cheo Walker writes in and
asks, is there a replacement
for core-list in Polymer 1.0?
So great question, Cheo.
Thank you for sending that in.
I'm actually really
happy to announce
that as of very recently,
we have just launched
the new iron-list element.
You can follow this link up
here to check out the repo.
It's the same core list
that you loved before
with all the cool, infinite
virtual scrolling goodness,
but ported over to Polymer 1.0.
So lot of really
awesome stuff there.
Cheo, thanks for sending
in that question.
I'm going to have my
minions reach out to you
and send you a swag pack.
If you out there watching--
if you have questions,
leave them for me
down in the comments.
I'm going to do my
best to respond.
And we just might feature you on
the next episode of Polycasts.
So again, thank you all
so much for watching,
and I'll see you next time.